Guten Morgen Linus.
Guten Morgen. Guten Morgen, Tim.
Weißt ja, was diese äh äh Sendung braucht, oder?
Hätten wir das ja jetzt auch endlich mal äh geschafft. Sondern es kann ja vorwerfen, dass wir hier nicht äh dem einundzwanzigsten Jahrhundert auf der Spur sind.
Sein. Konjunktiv.
Sein. Sonst kann er vorwerfen, dass wir.
Konjunktiv zwei sogar.
Gut, wie auch immer. Na ja. Aber der Konjunktiv, wir wissen, es ist sehr populär in der Politik und äh nicht nur in den normalen Politik, auch in dieser sonderlichen äh Spezialform der Politik, der,
Netzpolitik derer wir hier ein Logbuch sein wollen und äh meistens auch sind,
Das war so eine halbwegs halbwegs elegante halbwegs eleganter Einstieg hier in das Programm. Welches ist die zweiundfünfzigste Ausgabe hier vom Minus Neumann Podcast? Linus,
Auf dem Tisch.
Ich äh muss erst kurz überlegen, es gab, glaube ich, einen ähm,
Es gab ein Erratum, es gab sogar mehrere Iratten. Sagt man ja, mehrere ähm und ich aber eins davon war auf jeden Fall das Orange Schweiz, nicht zu dem Orange gehört,
Dass wir uns in der vorangegangenen Sendung nicht der großen Gruppe Orange gehört, über die wir uns beschwert haben,
in dem Moment als ich sagte, dass das wahrscheinlich jetzt genau das ein Orange ist, das nur ein Lizenznehmer ist und genau das ist es auch. Muss angemerkt sein. Also nicht alle orange sind,
Alle Oranges sind Orange, aber einige sind Oranger als die anderen.
Okay, das war relativ deutlich. Ansonsten war aber alles richtig.
Sowas würde ich nie behaupten.
Na ja, na ja. Wir bemühen uns. Wir begeben uns hier Mühe. Wir geben uns Mü.
Wir geben uns hier Mühe, ja. Ja.
Multimedial, crossmedial.
Wer sich auch Mühe gegeben hat, äh war ja die Enquete-Kommission Internet und digitale Gesellschaft.
Ja, die waren fleißig.
Ja, ja, genau, die ähm die strebt jetzt langsam ihrem ihrem Ende entgegen. Und zwar war da der äh die letzte, der letzte Sitzungstag. Zwanzig äh Stück davon haben sie, glaube ich, gemacht.
Stück dieser Sitzung.
Zwanzig Sitzungen, ja, zwanzig Enquete-Sitzungen gab es und äh wir haben die Enquete eigentlich glaube ich seit der ersten Sendung hier,
kaum noch erwähnt.
Haben wir es überhaupt erwähnt?
Ja, ich glaube, bei der ersten Sendung haben wir erwähnt, dass es sie gibt. Wenn man jetzt davon ausgehen.
Würde, dass wir so die relevanten Sachen der Netzpolitik behandeln,
Könnte man daraus einen Rückschluss auf die Relevanz der Enquete-Kommission, Internet und digitale Gesellschaft ziehen, äh die jetzt abschließend auch von ihren Mitgliedern sehr unterschiedlich bewertet wird? Ähm wir haben,
uns ja bemüht,
ein Mitglied der Enquete oder bei mehreren Mitgliedern der Enquete angefragt, aber leider keins für die Sendung bekommen können und deswegen hoffe ich immer noch, dass wir so eine Art ähm.
Resümee einfangen können, ja.
Nochmal bekommen von mindestens einem Mitglied in vielleicht einer Sondersendung oder so. Sondern? Ich würde vielleicht sogar sagen Sondersendung, ja.
Breaking.
Breaking. Ja, ich meine, zwölf äh Themen, die da behandelt wurden, ne? In zwölf,
hießen die dann Arbeitsgruppen oder was ist der, ja, zwölf Arbeitsgruppen, die sich über äh mit den Themen Bildung und Forschung, ein großes Thema Datenschutz und Persönlichkeitsrechte, Demokratie und Staat,
Internationales und Internet Governance, Interoparität, Standards und freie Software, Kultur, Medien und Öffentlichkeit, Medienkompetenz, Netzneutralität, Urheberrecht, Verbraucherschutz,
Wirtschaft, Arbeit, Green IT und Zugang, Struktur und Sicherheit im Netz. Das waren die zwölf Arbeitsgruppen. Ist ja schon relativ umfänglich.
Ja, vor allem könnte man sich wahrscheinlich zu jedem einzelnen Thema irgendwie auch zwanzig Sitzungen leisten können, ne. Genau. Mhm.
Genau. Ähm die äh diese Aufteilung und so äh also was was ja jeweils am Ende dieser zwölf äh Dinger stand, war ja dann eine Handlungsempfehlung,
Und diese Handlungsempfehlungen waren natürlich,
weil ja der Proports in diesem, in dieser Enquete auch dem Proports in der,
Bundestag entspricht war das natürlich auch der ungefähr immer dann doch der Regierungslinie entsprechend, weshalb Markus Becker da ja darauf hinweist, dass die äh Minderheiten das interessantere sind bei der Enquete. Ja also die,
sich also nicht gegen die Regierung äh durchsetzen konnten. Ähm.
Glaube ich, was man noch erwähnen kann, war so anfangs, was die die großen Themen der Enquete war ja, der diese Beteiligungsmöglichkeiten, dieses große Bohei, bis sie dann irgendwann mal ad hocrissy aufgesetzt haben.
Davon habe ich irgendwie gar nichts mitbekommen, du?
Nee, ich weiß auch nicht, ob da dann noch irgendwie groß was stattfand, ne. Also, es war, glaube ich, schon äh dieses riesige.
Na ja, okay, das at hocrissy kann man jetzt auch mal sagen, das Enquete Beteiligungs at hocrissy unter Enquete Beteiligung DE hat dreitausenddreihundertundneun Mitglieder. Da drin sind immerhin vier
vierhundertdreiundneunzig Vorschläge,
mit zweitausenddreihundertdreiundfünfzig Kommentaren versehen worden ähm und irgendwie insgesamt vierzehntausendfünfhundertachtundachtzig Stimmen abgegeben worden. Also da war offensichtlich was los,
ja, habe ich nicht ähm habe ich nicht so.
Also ich habe mich zwar mit so auseinandergesetzt, aber ehrlich gesagt äh mit hast du mal mit was gemacht?
Ich müsste jetzt zugeben, dass ich diese Enquete-Beteiligung DE zum ersten Mal sehe, seit sie dann damals gelauncht wurde und ich mir da mal kurz was angeschaut habe, aber seitdem war ich da nicht mehr drauf.
Ciao. So sind wir. Immer reden, ne, aber nichts machen.
Ja, also was äh was, glaube ich, interessant war, war,
Also diese Struktur, wer da so drin saß, ne, die Sachverständigen, siebzehn Abgeordnete, siebzehn Sachverständige, jeweils berufen von den einzelnen Fraktionen,
Ich glaube ja so aus,
Ja, wenn ich jetzt anfange, die Leute aufzuzählen, die da als Sachverständiger drin saßen, dann würden mir natürlich wieder welche äh entfallen, deswegen werde ich das mal,
ganz kurz äh werde ich einmal ganz kurz schummeln, wer da so alles drin war
Weil das sollte man ja vielleicht auch mal sagen, jetzt wo's jetzt wo's vorbei ist, kann man das ja nochmal resümieren. Danach muss man's ja nie wieder sagen. Äh Sachverständige, Markus Beckerdalm, Alvar Freude,
Professor Professor Doktor Hubertus Gersdorf, Professor Dieter Gorni, vielen Urheberrechtsfreunden, sehr bekannt. Äh Doktor Janette Hofmann, Konstanze kurz.
Was was zählst du jetzt genau auf.
Ich zähle die Sachverständigen auf.
Die Sachverständigung. Nach Fraktion äh sollten wir das vielleicht äh mal.
Das ist ja na ja die Sachverständigen, die sind ja gar nicht der Fraktion zugeordnet unbedingt. Sie sind ja nur von der Fraktion berufen.
Sind von den benannt, ja.
Ja, sie sind ja, also es es wäre jetzt ja fast äh was ein Frevel, den Sachverstand einer Fraktion zuzuordnen.
Es wäre ein Frevel einer Fraktion Sachverstand zuzuordnen.
Äh Konstanze kurz, Harald Lemke, Annette Mühlberg, Doktor Wolf Osthaus, Paddelun, Wolf, Doktor Professor Doktor Wolf-Dieter Ring. Doktor Bernhard Roleder, Lothar Schröder,
Professor Doktor Wolfgang Schulz, Nicole Simon, Cornelia Tausch und Professor Doktor Christoph Weinhardt. Ich habe die jetzt nur aufgezählt, damit ich sie alle genannt habe. Bitte frage mich jetzt nicht zu den.
Sowas.
Zu den einzelnen äh Herkünften und so weiter.
Wikipedia sehr schön aufgeführt. Es gibt natürlich zu dieser Enquete-Kommission auch einen eigenen Artikel, der das ähm sehr schön zusammenfasst.
Entscheidend ist, die werden also äh dann irgendwann ihre Abschlussberichte zu den einzelnen ähm zu den einzelnen Sachverständigen
Bereichen dort veröffentlichen und das wird, jetzt muss ich mal ganz kurz schauen, was wir da ähm,
irgendwie eine eine Anzahl der Seiten, die dieses Gremium produziert hat. Es war sehr äh war sehr beeindruckend.
Bei diesen diesen Handlungsempfehlungen ähm die Frage ist, weil die die unmittelbare politische Wirkung wird man da jetzt äh,
abwarten müssen, ja. Was haben wir hier? Da gab's einen Artikel auf Reise.
Also viele tausend Seiten stand da eine große Zahl und äh was ich eigentlich das einzige, was sehr, was sehr schön ist,
Was von dieser Barkett äh Enquette, glaube ich, direkt in Erinnerung bleiben wird, ist natürlich der Axel E Fischer,
Vorsitzende der.
Ein Spezialexperte.
Ein Spezialfachexperte und äh der hat äh sehr schön ähm immer wieder äh für für sehr viel Unterhaltung gesorgt,
Und so auch jetzt zum Abschluss gibt's noch mal einen ähm,
ein Achsel, ein Achseleffer zum Abschluss der Enquete, der also als äh Vorsitzender dieser Enquete-Kommission äh in seinem persönlichen Fazit am Montag feststellt, dass ihm erst nach und nach,
die Dimension der Veränderung klar geworden ist, die die Digitalisierung mit sich bringt.
Oh, das ist zwar tatsächlich für ihn, sagen wir mal, ein interessanter äh Lehrurlaub sozusagen.
War das eine interessante Sache. Er hat da viel gelernt. Und ähm das.
Schön für ihn. Ich weiß nicht, ob das Ihnen jetzt so im Rückblick unbedingt jetzt als Vorsitzenden äh qualifiziert. Man hätte ja auch jemanden nennen können, dem das schon vorher klar gewesen ist,
Hätte vielleicht was bringen können so, ne, aber na ja, war halt von der CDU, ich glaube nicht, dass sie da jetzt so viel zu holen hatten.
Du musst das anders sehen. Wenn die Arbeit der Enquete in der Lage ist, Axel Efischer etwas zu verdeutlichen, dann wurde.
Eigentlich schon gute Arbeit geleistet worden.
Gute Arbeit geleistet.
Das ist äh in der Tat. Ich meine, bei allem äh Hohen und Spott,
Äh ich höre auch immer wieder, ja, ich meine, gerade CDU äh äh ist natürlich jetzt genauso eine Art Organisation, wo es immer sehr schwierig ist, alles über einen Kamm zu scheren, ja? Und wir wissen alle, äh es gibt auch da äh progressive und aufgeklärte und äh weiterdenkende und auch sagen wir mal halbwegs
liberal äh denkende Menschen. Es gibt sie leider nicht nur. Ähm.
Die einen anderen äh Zugang haben zu der Gesellschaft, als wir das äh haben und von daher natürlich auch naturgemäß die Dinge etwas anders bewerten.
Trotzdem glaube ich da auch schon an eine gewisse ähm Lernfähigkeit
Also man sollte das zumindest nicht immer so äh grundsätzlich ausschließen, ne. Aber ist natürlich schon so ein bisschen merkwürdig, wenn er irgendwie dann so auftritt, dass er irgendwie ein Vermummungsverbot äh fordert im Internet und so weiter. Das ist alles so, ja.
Aber es ist auch so schwierig. Das ist auch so schwierig. Versuche das auch mal wieder selber, für mich so ein bisschen zu ergründen. Wenn du heute so auf das Netz stößt oder wenn du in den letzten fünf, was weiß ich, Jahren so, ne, also im politischen Prozess würde ich sagen, ist ja so das Internet eigentlich erst so vor vier, fünf Jahren entdeckt worden,
irgendwie, ach, das ist immer noch da, so,
Ja, man hat das schon mal gehört, aber es war bisher eher so ein so ein so ein bullet point bei irgendwie Internet Startups äh oder überhaupt bei Startups oder Firmen, sodass man das jetzt auch macht, so wie man irgendwie Katalysatoren in Autos einbaut und so. Aber dass das eben,
so ein fundamentaler Shift ist, ja, das ist denen neu. Und natürlich dadurch, dass sie so so spät dazugekommen sind.
Kann so eine schrittweise Sozialisierung, wie es die meisten von uns erfahren haben, natürlich eigentlich auch gar nicht mehr stattfinden. Und gerade so in das, das Verhältnis zu,
Anonymität, Pseudonymität. Ich denke, das ist schon etwas, was man eben erst so richtig erfühlen kann, wenn man über so einen längeren Zeitraum ähm,
das so miterlebt hat, welche Vor- und welche Nachteile äh das bringt. Und selbst das verändert sich ja auch äh immer noch. Also schwierig da mit Fingern zu zeigen, auch wenn's manchmal leicht ist, sich äh äh lustig zu machen. Trotzdem.
Habe ich so ein bisschen meine Zweifel, ob jetzt von dieser Enquete selbst auch irgendetwas ausgehen.
Na, ich fand das.
Also ob das sozusagen irgendein Wandel auf irgendeiner Ebene bringt, außer dass Axel Fischer halt verstanden hat. Das ist das die Digitalisierung nachhaltig ist.
Also ich finde das ein finde das einen wichtigen Aspekt, den den du benennst. Und wenn ich mir jetzt so vorstelle, ähm,
ungefähr so, wie du das jetzt grade äh beschrieben hast, stelle ich mir vor wie Historiker das in äh in vielleicht hundert Jahren dann,
äh so man muss sich das vorstellen, da gab es eine Gesellschaft und irgendwann mussten sie eine Enquete-Kommission einberufen,
Um äh um irgendwie so ein ihre ganze Regierung irgendwie mal daran zu gewöhnen, dass es das gibt,
Handlungsempfehlungen in allen Bereichen machen. So wird das, glaube ich, historisch auch. Und da wird man genau diesen Clash ähm drin benennen, den du nämlich gerade auch beschrieben hast, den man in der Gesellschaft, innerhalb der Generation hat und den man auch in der Politik sieht und der dann
genau zu solchen Äußerungen führt, wo man äh wo die eine Hälfte der Gesellschaft sich drüber schrottlacht,
eine andere Hälfte, nämlich diese, die noch nicht mit Breitband versorgt ist, äh eventuell äh gar nicht weiß, was daran lustig ist.
Und sich das gerne von Axel Efischer nochmal erklären lassen würde,
Ich denke, was sie insgesamt, also es gibt da jetzt, wie gesagt, diese diese Abschlussberichte. Ich finde hier auf der Webseite nicht wirklich äh mir ist jetzt nicht ganz klar, ob die IS in einiger in in den nächsten Tagen dann veröffentlichen oder so. Ähm.
Ich glaube, das gibt's noch nicht, sonst wäre das hier wahrscheinlich auch in dem Wikipedia Artikel drin, ja.
Ja und es gab zwischen den ähm,
zwischen den dort sitzenden ja auch immer wieder äh Zankereien auch denjenigen Vertretern, der
Netz-Community, die dort saßen, ja, also was dann bestimmte Entscheidungen anging beim bei den Votum zur Netzneutralität und und was da nicht alles los war, aber
ich würde da, wie gesagt, lieber jemanden befragen, der dort tatsächlich drin gesessen hat und hoffe, dass wir das in den nächsten Wochen noch irgendwie hinkriegen,
da mal mit äh Markus oder Konstanze zum Beispiel zu sprechen.
Bemühen, soweit äh halten wir uns jetzt erstmal hier mit einer Bewertung äh zurück, denn ihr merkt schon, man hätte sich da besser drauf vorbereiten können, beziehungsweise es vielleicht auch noch intensiver begleiten können.
Jahre, wer hätte sich das die letzten Jahre angucken.
Ja, aber es äh ist es war jetzt nicht unbedingt jetzt äh das Spannendste.
In der Tat, also das ist ja haben ja auch einige Mitglieder sogar äh öffentlich so geäußert, ne, dass sie sich mit der ähm dass sie da jetzt nicht ihre ihr Herzblut in dieser Arbeit gesteckt haben.
Ja, schade, aber nachvollziehbar.
So, was haben wir noch? Da unser Dauerbrenner.
Ja, Dauerbrenner, Leistungsschutzrecht,
dass das Leistungsschutzrecht hatte eine Anhörung im im Rechtsausschuss des Bundestages, wenn ich das jetzt richtig sehe oder im richtigen Bundestag schon mal äh nee, im im Rechtsausschutz war das,
Ja, die einzige Anhörung. Und äh in diesem,
haben wir auch wieder sowas, ne? Die Sachverständigen der Fraktion nach Proports eingeladen, ähnlich wie in der äh Enquete-Kommission nur nicht so viele. Ähm,
Und da wurde dann jetzt diskutiert. Es war wie immer im äh wie das im,
Parlament so ist. Äh alle sagen ihre äh ihre Meinung, die Sachverständigen äh sagen
äh sagen ihren Sachverstand und am Ende gehen alle mit genau der gleichen Ansicht da wieder raus wie
sie reingekommen sind, das heißt, sie hat sich natürlich nichts an den an den Mengen oder Kräfteverhältnissen bei dieser Entscheidung geändert.
Und im Moment sieht es, also es gibt da es gibt da einen sehr schönen Artikel. Wer sich, wer ja wirklich, glaube ich, inzwischen der der beste Liveblogger oder der, der, der, der, ja, der, der,
beste Live-Blogger Deutschlands ist, ist ja Matthias Schindler, der ähm auch von dieser äh,
Anhörung im Bundestag dann da gelife blockt hat, weil die aus irgendwelchen Gründen nicht ins Netz gestreamt wurde,
ähm das sieht immer sehr ähm sehr nicht besonders leserfreundlich aus, so ein Live-Blog, wo dann also wo ein Blogartikel geschrieben, alle paar Minuten gespeichert,
wird und man liest dann so neu und sieht was Neues dazugekommen ist, wenn äh Matthias Schiller das macht, ist das aber ähm sehr sehr äh sehr lustig,
kann man ähm kann man durchaus mal lesen. Ähm eventuell wird's sich da im Nachhinein nochmal anbieten, das irgendwie
Insgesamt lese freundlicher zu gestalten. Aber da gibt's also ein schönes Liveblog von dieser Anhörung. Aber, wie gesagt, inhaltlich ist da nichts passiert. Insofern ist das äh,
Unterhaltung zu werten, was da stattgefunden hat. Also im Sinne von Entertainment, aber nicht im Sinne von ähm,
politischen Prozess, der da jetzt statt tatsächlich stattgefunden hätte.
Und der es sieht also jetzt danach aus, der Rechtsausschuss könnte schon in drei Wochen seine Beschlussempfehlung rausgeben,
Die Leute dann natürlich, wir empfehlen, ja, zu beschließen. Dann könnte das,
Der Bundestag im Plenum schon am zweiundzwanzigsten Februar über das Gesetz abstimmen?
Wenn es bei dieser einen Anhörung bliebe. Wenn jetzt die Opposition hingeht und sagt, wir wollen aber noch äh ein oder zwei weitere Ausschussanhörungen haben.
Dann,
ist es vielleicht 'ne Verzögerung irgendwie um ein, zwei Monate und wir werden immer noch irgendwie im Quartal eins Quartals Anfang Quartal zwei, zweitausendzwölf, dreizehn, das äh
dass das Gesetz in den Bundestag kommt und dort mit den Mehrheitsverhältnissen beschlossen wird. Jetzt wird's spannend, was äh den Bundesrat angeht.
Denn im ähm Bundesrat könnten,
Die Verhältnisse anders aussehen, vor allem äh jetzt nach der äh Niedersachsen-Wahl und was dann ähm.
Was heißt könnten?
Na, sie na, sie könnten, ja genau, sie könnten, weil äh also sie sehen im Prinzip anders aus, wenn,
Ähm jetzt, wenn man so nach Fraktionen oder nach Parteien geht,
aber in der Partei gibt's ja auch so einige, die dann sagen, äh in der, in der SPD gibt's ja zum Beispiel Leute, die sagen so, ja ähm ne da hängen Arbeitsplätze dran oder so, ne? Und deswegen müssen wir hier
entsprechend so und so entscheiden. Also das heißt eine eine Ablehnung im Bundesrat schätzt schätzt man jetzt auch nicht so.
Weil's die SPD geführten Länder könnten für das Leistungsschutzrecht stimmen.
Sie wollen es verbessern statt ablehnen.
Verbessern
Na ja gut, ich meine, das ist ja in dem wesentlichen die Tätigkeit des Bundesrats, da ist ja äh selten eine komplette Verweigerungshaltung, das gab's auch, ja, aber äh in der Regel ist es ja so, dass ähm ja,
Verbesserungen gefordert werden, dann geht es in diesen Vermittlungsausschuss und dann einigt man sich noch auf den einen oder anderen Paragraphen und im Wesentlichen geht es doch so durch wie,
mal geplant, bloß mit irgendwelchen Abfederungen, aber kein ähm generellen, strukturellen Veränderungen.
Genau. Ja, das wäre dann also das, das, das äh steht hier als Befürchtung an, ja? So könnte gut sein, dass wir das relativ.
Aber das kann ja auch noch ein bisschen dauern.
Ja, wenn man das jetzt richtig übel raushandelt mit den, mit den ähm,
mit den äh Nachverhandlungen und so, ja und irgendwie dann das Ganze in den Vermittlungsausschuss geht und so weiter, dann,
Könnte man es schaffen, dass das Diskontinuitätsprinzip zur Anwendung kommt, welches besagt, dass nach einem,
Nach dem Ende einer, na, ich muss mal ganz kurz gucken. Nicht, dass ich das jetzt falsch zitiere.
Äh ja, nach dem Ende einer Legislaturperiode ähm.
Ein eine sachliche, personelle und organisatorische Erneuerung stattfindet und deswegen die Debatte, also das Gesetzesvorhaben nicht ähm,
weiterverfolgt wird, sondern eben verfällt. Man müsste quasi eine neue Gesetzesinitiative beginnen.
Also sprich, wenn es in dieser Legislaturperiode nicht einfach durchgewunken wird und beschlossen und gesetzkräftig wird, dann
muss es im Prinzip äh fallen gelassen werden. Es sei denn, dass da eben dieselbe Regierung weiter regiert, äh die derzeit so am Staat ist,
Gut, das müssen wir sehen, ne? Also mein Tipp ist ja immer noch, das kommt nicht.
Ja, aber du hast irgendwie keinen empirischen Anhaltspunkt dafür.
Nee, es äh reines Bauchgefühl. Reines Bauchgefühl, weil ich mir einfach denke, kann nie sein. Also äh meine,
Einschätzung ist ja, wenn das nicht durch die Legislative äh schon gestoppt wird,
auf den letzten Metern. Was ja jetzt durchaus auch sein könnte, ja? Dann äh gibt's ja dann immer noch so die höheren Instanzen,
Also der Bundespräsident wird jetzt sicherlich äh kein äh Problem darstellen, aber verfassungs äh äh Gericht sehe ich hier an der Stelle auf jeden Fall nochmal ähm im Ring,
die dann wirklich angerufen werden. Das werden wir nochmal sehen, aber ich würde das auch nicht ausschließen.
Denkbar ist es.
Ist nicht auch jetzt irgendwie in die äh äh Debatte, um das Leistungsschutzrecht äh eingestiegen. Ich hatte da irgendwie sowas noch in Erinnerung, die äh leben ja jetzt wieder, seitdem sie sich,
Yahoo ist ja jetzt äh revitalisiert worden durch äh einerseits Personal von Google und andererseits durch äh Vieltritte anderer äh Unternehmen.
Die da jetzt das Zepter schwingt, die äh hat schon einige sehr interessante äh,
Weichenstellungen vorgenommen, so dass das äh vielleicht durchaus nochmal was werden könnte. Die machen auch wieder Gewinn. Also,
davon unabhängig hatte ich gehört, dass sie sich jetzt da auch nochmal einmischen wollen und im Prinzip so ähnlich wie Google da an der Stelle rin und was ich sehr interessant fand an ihrer Argumentation,
war, dass sie der Meinung sind, dass dieses Gesetz ja Google zu Gute kommen würde.
Ja, natürlich kommt das äh wie, hä? Ähm okay, das würde mich jetzt interessieren, wie kommen also was.
Weil es sozusagen äh am Ende, wie wir das ja hier auch schon ein paar Mal äh diskutiert hatten, ja, dass äh darauf hinausläuft, dass eben spezielle Deals mit Google gemacht werden könnten, ja?
Aber eben,
nur mit Google, weil Platzhirsch, Marktführer, et cetera und kleinere Suchmaschinen und äh sonstige äh Infoanbieter im Netz da eben äh zu kurz kommen können, weil die eben nicht so ein hohes Gewicht haben und eben nicht so gute Deals raus äh holen können. Also ich,
Paraphasiere äh jetzt mal das, was ich gelesen habe. Ich äh müsste es äh vielleicht auch nochmal gegen den,
Text. Dessen linke ich jetzt grade nicht zur Hand habe. Ähm abchecken, aber,
das fand ich nochmal einen ganz interessanten Vorstoß an der Stelle, ob das jetzt lobbytechnisch noch viel bewirkt, weiß ich nicht, aber äh
meiner Meinung nach ist einfach die Interesselage immer noch so, dass es einfach genug Leute gibt, die da gar keinen Spaß mit haben, ja, die auch nicht bereit sind, da die Konsequenzen zu fressen und dementsprechend äh
die noch zur Verfügung stehenden Instanzen auch ausschöpfen würden. Aber das ist nichts anderes als ein so eine Wette von mir. Ja, also es ist jetzt kein,
Eine juristische Einschätzung in eine solche kann ich nicht vornehmen.
Dieses dieses Problem, dass dass da,
sich eine große Allianz im Prinzip bindet, das hatten wir ja oder hatte ich ja schon mal angesprochen, aber du hast Recht, wir man muss hoffen, dass es irgendwie,
man kann sich über jeden freuen, der sich dagegen ausspricht, aber da wir inzwischen irgendwie jeden Sachverständigen, jeden ernstzunehmenden Wissenschaftler und alle sich irgendwie dagegen ausgesprochen haben, trotzdem sich nichts daran ändert, ähm.
Ja, ne, ich meine, vielleicht läuft's ja jetzt einfach auf so eine Fili-Busterei da äh hinaus, im Bundes äh Rat, ja, dass da irgendwie jetzt so lange Reden gehalten werden und äh äh Anhörung äh gefordert und Vermittlungsausschüsse einberufen werden äh äh bis halt
die Sache überhaupt nicht äh mehr vorankommt,
Auch wenn man jetzt wirklich so den Eindruck hat, dass eben Schwarz-Gelb das jetzt auch noch wirklich gerne vor der nächsten Bundestagswahl äh durchkriegen will, damit Springer nicht so böse über sie schreibt,
Obwohl ich mir das irgendwie ehrlich gesagt nicht vorstellen kann, dass die dann trotzdem fallen lassen, weil dass sie jetzt mit der Opposition so sehr viel besser fahren, glaube ich nicht, dass das,
Ihre Meinung ist. Am Ende müssen sie auch nehmen, was sie kriegen können. Tja, nächstes Thema.
Ein ähm Gesetzesvorhaben, von dem wir vor einiger Zeit hier wohlwollend berichtet haben,
scheint ähm nun auch zahnlos zu werden und zwar.
Price.
Surprise, ja? Ähm ging es da um die Deckelung von äh von Abmahnungen. Aber insgesamt um eine ähm,
größeres Gesetzesvorhaben von ähm die aus aus dem Justizministerium kommend, also von unserer Frau Leuthäuser Schnarrenberger,
dass äh hauptsächlich zum Verbraucherschutz äh dienen
soll und zwar, in dem es sich unter anderem gegen Telefonwerbung, insbesondere für Glücksspieldienste
wendet, also es gibt da irgendwie wohl Abzockenmethoden, dass die Leute irgendwie am Telefon. Wollen sie nicht auch an unserer Lotterie teilnehmen? Ach ja, äh das dann als äh Unterzeichnung eines Vertrages werten und dann äh entsprechend Geld kassieren für für das Glücksspiel. Ähm,
Außerdem gibt es wohl eine Masche von Inkasso-Firmen, die ähm per Telefon oder was ähm nicht äh nicht,
Existierende Forderungen eintreiben,
Ähm dagegen soll auch äh irgendwie was getan werden und gegen den Abmahnwahn, ja? Ähm wir,
von den von den horrent teuren Abmahnungen, die immer wieder bei Leuten eingehen.
Insbesondere was angeht dagegen soll soll sich ja diese Gesetzesinitiative wenden und denen ein äh eine Art Kostendeckelung verpassen, ja?
Und ähm darüber lesen wir jetzt in der Süddeutschen Zeitung, dass äh Leute also erstmal grundsätzlich ähm,
Die Gebühren in solchen Fällen generell deckeln wollte. Aber ähm die Unionsfraktion hat sie dann ähm,
Doch mal ähm ja, ein bisschen wieder in ihre Richtung gezerrt und sie darauf hingewiesen, dass ja das Geistige Eigentum im Internet mit Füßen getreten wird und ähm,
deshalb äh zu einem, sie zu einem Kompromiss gedrängt hat und gesagt, dass äh diese Abmahnungsdeckelung nur dann gilt.
Wenn es nicht gewerblich ist. Also es ist quasi im gewerblichen Ausmaß, bei Fallshering, im gewerblichen Ausmaß, gilt die Kostendeckelung nicht.
Und ähm das ist aber auch im heutigen,
Urheberrecht schon so, dass du für nicht gewerbliches Fightsharing nicht abgemahnt werden kannst.
Das Ding ist, dass sie,
Die klassische Rechtsprechung ist, dass Falsharing gewerbliches, also Fallschirm zum Beispiel via Bitorent oder Bereitstellung auf der auf dem deiner Wahl,
gewerbliches Ausmaß hat.
Per per Design sozusagen.
Wegen der wegen des enormen gewerblichen Schädigungspotentials, was mit der allgemeinen.
Also selbst wenn du es nicht gewerblich machst, hat es ja einen Einfluss auf ein Gewerbe und ist damit gewerblich. Das ist auch eine geile Argument.
Das ist der allgemeine Interpretationskonsens. Ähm und das macht's natürlich äh schwierig,
Ich warte, ich suche nochmal ganz kurz den den entsprechenden genauen Artikel raus, den hat da der liebe Andre ähm sogar verlinkt, so Urheberrechtsgesetz, siebenundneunzig A Abmahnungen.
Der Ersatz, der erforderlichen, wo steht's gewerbmäßig.
Ja, der Ersatz der erforderlichen Aufwendung für die Inanspruchnahme anwaltlicher Dienstleistung für die erstmalige Abmahnung beschränkt sich in einfach gelagerten Fällen mit nur einer unerheblichen Rechtsverletzung außerhalb des geschäftlichen Verkehrs.
Auf einhundert Euro. Das heißt, wir haben schon eine Deckelung. Und genau die wird aber umgangen, weil man sagt, das ist eine,
Erhebliche innerhalb des geschäftlichen Verkehrs und damit ist eben diese Deckelung nicht mehr ähm.
Also sonst gibt's sozusagen eine Deckelung, die aber nie äh aufgerufen werden kann, weil sie bei Design eigentlich nie aufgerufen werden kann.
Es wird einfach gesagt, dass äh.
So, das heißt, die die Neufassung äh äh äußert sich da, ich habe jetzt auch da geht es doch auch um eine Deckelung. Aber diese Deckelung greift nur äh beim ersten Mal, oder?
Ja ähm.
Also wenn man das erste Mal eine Urheberrechtsverletzung begeht.
Bei einer bestimmten Person, also es ist ja bei der ist ja eine Abmahnung, das ist ja nicht generell, also ich meine,
Wenn ich jetzt quasi deine Rechte einmal verletze, ist das erste Mal. Wenn ich dann nochmal die von äh was weiß ich, Sven Regener verletzt, dann ist es natürlich auch das erste Mal. Wenn ich dann aber nochmal seine Rechte verletze, dann wär's.
Also sozusagen pro Verletzten Rechtskörper.
Für dich jetzt so.
Äh pro Artist sozusagen, gibt's eigentlich eine Deckelung, sodass ich sozusagen immer nur für was ist da der Preis, der genannt wurde, hundertfünfundfünfzig Euro dreißig,
auch eine geile Zahl
ja warum nicht warum nicht hundertneunundvierzig neunundneunzig? Da wüsste man wenigstens sofort woran man ist ja? Vielleicht sollte man auch
da einfach mal so Supermarkt, kompatible Preise äh nennen, damit die Leute einfach wissen, so jetzt hier Urheberrechtsverletzungen für nur neunundneunzig neunundneunzig.
Ja, aber es wird also dann in einer äh Pressemitteilung des Vereins digitale Gesellschaft korrekt darauf hingewiesen, dass wenn man jetzt sagt, ähm wenn man diese Pläne auf das gewerbliche Ausmaß,
ein also wenn man dieses Gesetz ein ähm auf das gewerbliche Ausmaß,
Durch das gewerbliche im Ausmaß einschränkt, dann äh wird der ambitionierte oder auch nicht besonders ambitionierte Fallschirm überrascht feststellen, dass er gewerblich handelt und deswegen überhaupt nichts davon hat, ja.
Also mit anderen Worten, wenn das jetzt so durchkäme, dann würde sich eigentlich gar nichts änder.
So interpretiere ich die.
Dass man jetzt beim ersten Mal, was auch immer, das erste Mal ist, äh nur hundertfünfundfünfzig Euro hat, aber wenn dieselbe Bude nochmal anschreibt, dann liegt sie schon wieder mehr drauf.
Ja, ich denke, es geht ich denke, es geht sogar sehr viel weiter, dass sie sagen, in dem Moment, wo es ein Torent ist, äh.
Und da sind irgendwie, weiß ich nicht so und so viele Leute in diesem äh swam und dann ist halt fertig, dann ist das gewerbliches Ausmaß, Punkt. So, die die Latte reißt du sehr schnell.
Na ja.
Hm? So, also da ist dieses schöne Gesetz äh und da wird also mehrfach der Name des Herrn,
Günther Krings und Unionsfraktionsvize äh genannt, der da also die federführende Rolle gespielt hat, das Ding nochmal umzubiegen, danke.
Danke, Günther.
Gut gemacht. Nicht, dass hier noch jemand das Urheberrecht mit Füßen tritt.
Nee, nee, nee.
So
Urheberrecht mit Füßen getreten, wird auch von der GEMA beziehungsweise von YouTube beide beschuldigen sich gegenseitig dessen.
Wir haben ja.
Darüber gesprochen, was also die
Klage zwischen beiden angeht. Ich glaube in der letzten oder vorletzten Sendung. Da gibt's jetzt ein interessantes äh Detail, nämlich die Gamer wollte ja jetzt eine,
wollte ja jetzt YouTube, beziehungsweise hinter
YouTube stehende Google, verklagen auf Schadensersatz und wat nicht alles. Ja ähm und da war jetzt der der Treff ist, dass die Gamer leider äh äh diese Klage erstmal daran scheitert, dass die GEMA nicht weiß, wo sie die,
wo sie die zustellen muss, ja? Ähm,
zunächst den, den deutschen Sitz von von Google angegeben,
Äh und Google Ink hat zwar hat zwar YouTube gekauft, aber äh YouTube operiert immer noch als eigenständige Firma, die keinen Firmensitz in Deutschland hat,
Das heißt, sie müssen ihre Klage eigentlich an YouTube irgendwie in,
Kalifornien adressieren. Und das heißt, da können wir jetzt erstmal nochmal mit ein paar Wochen Verzögerungen warten.
Scheinen sich ja richtig äh richtig schlau gemacht zu haben so. Ich meine, es hat ja jetzt nur mehrere Jahre gedauert, ja, bis sie herausgefunden haben, dass ihr Gegner überhaupt nicht in Deutschland ist.
Ja, also das finde ich ja schon bemerkenswert. Insbesondere vor dem Hintergrund, dass sie ja schon offensichtlich die ein oder andere Anbahnung von Deals zumindest probiert haben. Ich meine, die saßen doch mit denen schon an einem Tisch.
Ja
Oder oder war das, haben die, haben die sich irgendwie nur über, haben die nur über Insta-Messaging miteinander kommuniziert. Nur so, ja, so, ja, hu, Messenger, irgendwie, MSN.
Ich glaube, an der Stelle darf man nicht nur über die GEMA lachen. Also ähm äh wenn ich das richtig in Erinnerung habe, haben die ihre Verhandlungen und Diskussionen dann durchaus auch mit Google Deutschland geführt,
die äh dann da quasi ein Mandat in diesen Verhandlungen hatten von der Mutter Google, äh die ihm über über YouTube herrscht. Und jetzt haben sie's eben an den Falschen geschickt, ja. Ist aber.
Meine, was ist denn das für eine Rechtsabteilung?
Klassische, ich war ein klassisches Problem irgendwie im Internet, ne? Ich meine, schau dir das an, was die ganze Datenschutz äh Gesetz basierte Flucht von Google nach Irland angeht und so, das ist schon
teilweise schwierig da zu wissen, wen du jetzt tatsächlich verklagst, ja? Die haben ja auch kein Interesse daran, äh,
Das einfach zu machen. Ja, also pikantes Detail, hier müssen wir also mit ein paar Wochen Verzögerung rechnen, bis das Ding dann irgendwie äh in äh USA angekommen ist, diese Klage, ja? Aber, aber es es läuft auf jeden Fall weiter.
Währenddessen ähm hat YouTube offensichtlich so eine Art Beta-Funktion vorgestellt und zwar eine Art Musikradiergummi,
Ja, das ist also auch ganz süß. Ähm ist noch nicht für alle Videos verfügbar, aber man lädt quasi etwas hoch. Und dann,
ohne ohne Garantie sagt YouTube dann hör mal, ich glaube.
Da ist irgendwie urheberrechtlich geschützte Musik in deinem Video, also beispielsweise ein Partyvideo, bei dem im Hintergrund äh ein ein Song läuft,
Und ähm,
dann bieten sie dir so eine Audiobearbeitung an, diesen Song quasi rauszuretuschieren. Während alle anderen Geräusche vorhanden bleiben. Also sie blenden quasi die Hintergrundmusik aus oder den Song selber. Ähm,
bieten natürlich nicht 'ne Gewährleistung dafür, dass das dass dieses Verfahren tatsächlich klappt oder dass sie auch alles erkennen, aber sie bieten's irgendwie mal an,
Keine Ahnung, warum sie das jetzt machen. Ähm ich glaube, der Effekt, auf den sie abzielen, ist einerseits,
Den Nutzern zu ermöglichen ähm.
Diese das tatsächlich zu zu tun, ja, wenn bevor ihr Video nachher gesperrt werdet in Deutschland. Äh andererseits glaube ich aber auch, dass sie
Durchaus auch machen, um mal so die diese absolute Absurdität einfach mal aufzuzeigen und der GEMA so ein bisschen die den,
Den starken Arm zu zeigen und zu sagen, hör mal bei Jungs, gar kein Problem, wenn ihr hier nicht bei uns drauf sein wollt, dann können wir das gerne.
Aber interessant ist äh Feature, ja.
Kann man auch dann wieder an- und ausschalten, ja? Also sie machen dein Video nicht nicht dauerhaft kaputt. Hm? Auf jeden Fall mal ganz.
Scheint ja, scheint ja ganz gut zu funktionieren. Ich habe ja jetzt hier schon seit einer viertel Stunde Gamo-Musik im Hintergrund laufen. Ich weiß nicht, ob du irgendwas gehört hast, so.
Ich habe nix gehört.
Ja, also ne?
Und dann kommt natürlich vor vor dem Hintergrund dieser gesamten Debatte kommt jetzt,
Open Data City ins Spiel. Ähm das ist der Datenjournalisten, um Michael Kreil und Lorenz Mazad.
Die äh.
Ja hier schon mal zu Gast. Damals ging's da um mehr um die Bahn, aber ist halt äh da hier unsere Open Data. Äh Armeefraktion, die
immer mit sehr äh schönen Beispielen und äh,
ohne sich jetzt zu sehr um wie man das eigentlich zu machen hat groß zu scheren die Dinge dann mal versucht zu,
visualisieren und zu dokumentieren und in diesem Fall haben sie sich halt mal dieser Problematik der Sperrung angenommen,
sehr schöne Sache. Und zwar haben sie durch allerlei Tricks ähm es geschafft, herauszufinden, äh was die auf YouTube ist,
Das Interessante daran ist.
Tausend. Haben sie uns ausgeweitet auf die Top tausend.
Genau. Top äh äh also so die die tausend populärsten Videos. Jetzt mag man sich denken so, naja okay, dann nimmt man die halt und checkt das mal durch. Das Ding ist, du kriegst diese Zahl gar nicht so ohne weiteres. Also ähm YouTube ähm.
Äh nach Gutdünken solche Anfragen, wenn irgendwie da über die APGs und es ist nicht so ganz so einfach, das äh zu machen,
Aber trotzdem ähm Wege gefunden,
durch wiederholtes Durchsuchen des Materials dann über die entsprechenden Angaben, über wie viele Leute denn das so gesehen haben angeblich.
Eben so eine Liste zu machen und haben dann eben mal geschaut, was ist denn davon jetzt konkret eigentlich gesperrt in Deutschland und was ist auch gesperrt in anderen Staaten,
Ich weiß nicht, haben Sie alle Staaten,
Viele Staaten, manche Staaten, also ich glaube, sie haben mal so geschaut, ähm wie das so in den USA und äh europäischen Ländern steht und ähm,
auch.
Also ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher, ob sie wirklich alle
alle Länder der Welt ausprobiert haben. Ich habe mich vor ein paar Tagen mit Michael da mal ein bisschen drüber unterhalten. Die haben unter anderem auch teilweise Schwierigkeiten gehabt, sich so YouTube glaubhaft zu simulieren, aus welchem Land sie gerade kommen,
Ähm aber man kann mal davon ausgehen, dass sie äh schon relativ viele Länder untersucht haben. Sie haben insgesamt,
äh einfach immer nach den nach den Videos mit mehr als vierzig Millionen,
Zuschauer mehr als vierzig Millionen Klicks gefragt und da YouTube halt immer eine andere Antwort gibt, haben sie einfach zweihunderttausend Mal mit ihrem Scraper gefragt,
und dadurch dann diese Liste der Top eintausend gestellt. Und ähm,
Jetzt haben sie sich angeschaut, von diesem, als sie dann diese Liste der Top eintausend hatten,
Wie viele davon kann man aus welchem Land aufrufen? Sind dann quasi einfach hingegangen, haben YouTube immer vorgespielt, hallo, wir sind jetzt hier, wir kommen aus Deutschland und wir würden gerne dieses Video sehen.
Und dann hat äh YouTube ihnen geantwortet, ah aus Deutschland, ja äh sorry äh könnte GEMA Musik drin sein, ja? Dürfen wir dir nicht zeigen. Und das Spannende ist,
Der Vergleich der Zahlen, ja. In Deutschland gesperrt von den Top eintausend? Sechshundertfünfzehn.
Also einundsechzig Komma fünf Prozent der meistgesehenen YouTube-Videos finden ohne Deutschland statt.
Wenn man dann mal das aufschüsselt nach bestehenden Rechteproblemen, dann sind das nur acht Komma vier Prozent.
Was heißt das? Bestehende Rechteprobleme, wo es ganz klar ist, dass da.
Ja, wo's genau, wo's wo's offensichtlich rechte Probleme gibt und bei den verbleibenden dreiundfünfzig Prozent sind es dann möglicherweise rechte Problem.
Kann das denn überhaupt überprüft werden?
Ähm da müsstest du jetzt nochmal im Detail fragen, wie sie's gemacht haben. Vielleicht entweder steht's so in der AP drin, dass sie sagen, es gibt tatsächlich ein ein rechte Problem. Ähm,
oder äh also ich weiß nicht genau, ob das, ob das sich aus dem YouTube äh Blocking Code irgendwie erkennen lässt oder das weiß ich nicht genau, wie sie's gemacht haben. Das Interessante ist, ich vertraue, dass sie es richtig gemacht haben. Und wenn man sich jetzt anschaut,
ähm.
Also was ich was ich ja sehr spannend daran finde ist, ich habe als ich dann mit Michael drüber geredet habe, habe ich gesagt, du das naja, habt ihr jetzt eigentlich YouTube ein riesen,
Kampagnenfutter gegeben, weil diese Zahl absolut absurd ist, wenn man sie nämlich mit dem, mit einem anderen Staat vergleicht,
der äh zum Beispiel Südsudan heißt.
Das fühlt sich unglaublich,
Land sich überhaupt darum so groß kümmert, ne?
Ich äh versuche grade die Zahl von in Südsudan waren es wie viel Prozent? Ich gucke jetzt gerade ganz kurz ähm.
Es gibt diese diese Übersicht, Moment, wo haben wir sie denn? Jetzt bin ich bei denen schon im Blog schon wieder ganz woanders. Ähm.
Ich hab's hier aufm Beamer.
Du hast es, ja aber zeig doch mal, ah ja, Südsudan, da waren's dann irgendwie nee, aber das ist nicht äh so zack, mehr Info. Ich werde dir genauer Zahl gerne.
Fünfzehn Prozent.
Ich kann's irgendwie nicht. Ah ja, Süd zu, ja, jetzt haben sie ja nur ein Bild.
Fünfzehn Prozent. Vierzehn, fünfzehn, sechzehn.
Vierzehn, fünfzehn Prozent, so versus die sechzig Prozent, die wir in Deutschland haben. Ah, jetzt sehe ich die ganze. Ja, guck mal hier. Südsudan, äh fünfzehn Komma drei Prozent, hm Vatikan, fünf Prozent,
Und so geht es dann weiter, ja, in den USA, weniger als ein Prozent in den Österreich, eins Komma ein Prozent. Das heißt, wir äh das einzige Land äh der Erde, was noch ein zweistelligen,
Äh Prozentbetrag an Sperrungen auf YouTube hat, hat immer noch ein Vier.
Der top eintausend wohlgemerk.
Top eintausend, ja genau, der.
Aller Videos.
Top eintausend, der Top eintausend hat immer noch nur ein Viertel der Sperrung, die Deutschland hat. So, interessant ist aber, dass natürlich dieser Teil der,
Möglicherweise rechte Probleme. Der A verbirgt sich das Kampagnenfutter der GEMA.
Man muss auch, glaube ich, noch eine Sache mal generell hier relativieren, damit die Diskussion nicht zu zu affig wird, ja?
Ist doch nicht affig.
Doch,
in einem, also könnt sein könnte, wenn man's jetzt nicht erwähnt, deswegen möchte ich das jetzt mal erwähnen. Wir reden jetzt hier von einer Sperrung wegen der GEMA, wegen nicht geklärter Musikrechte. Im Südsudan,
ja, ist das, glaube ich, weniger das Thema
ja, sondern da geht es deutlich mehr um religiös äh politisch motivierte äh äh Dinge und ich vermute mal, das wird auch in den Vatikan statt und äh Grönland und Burma und äh Palästina et cetera,
ähnlich seid, ja? Die kümmern sich da glaube ich weniger um Verwertungsrechte für ihre Musiker. Ja, auch wenn man vielleicht argumentieren könnte, dass sie es mal besser tun sollten. Dann würden sie auch eine höhere Sperrquote äh erzielen, aber
ist es halt trotzdem einfach eine eine krasse Zahl, weil dadurch wird überhaupt erstmal bewusst, wie groß da die Explosion ist,
man kann da jetzt auch irgendwie mit dieser GEMA-Logik rangehen und sagen, na ja, das ist ja illegal und wisst ihr, wie das Urheberrecht ist? Und.
GEMA-Logik, das ist ja nicht die GEMA Look, die GEMA Logida, deswegen sage ich, das Interessante ist bei diesen möglicherweise rechte Problemen. Die GEMA-Logik sagt,
Natürlich könnt ihr die zeigen, ihr müsst nur bezahlen.
Und YouTube sagt, nee, dann zeigen wir es lieber gar nicht. Deswegen gehen wir ja auch nicht. Insofern ähm also die GEMA ist ja ich muss ja immer betonen, die GEMA geht ja nicht dahin und sagt, ihr müsst das sperren.
Die GEMA hat irgendwann mal exemplarisch zwölf Videos sperren lassen. Äh und YouTube hat seitdem äh angefangen, einfach alles zuzumachen. Das heißt, das finde ich nämlich das Spannende mit den möglicherweise Rechteproblemen, dass,
diese Zahl,
Und das ist ja das Schöne an vernünftigen statistischen Erhebungen, für beide Seiten einfach meine eine MP eine vernünftige empirische Faktenbasis äh
Schafft jetzt hier in diesem Beispiel anhand der tausend beliebtesten, weltweit beliebtesten Musikvideos, was eben auch eine sehr ähm,
Also kann man sich fragen, wie wie ähm,
Wie repräsentativ so eine Stichprobe ist, weil ein Land wie Südsudan,
relativ wenige Einwohner hat im Vergleich zu den vierzig Millionen, die notwendig sind für einen ähm für eine Positionierung in diesen Top eintausend,
Das heißt, ähm eventuell quasi die, wenn man sich jetzt die Top eintausend der Süd-Sudanesischen Videos anschaut.
Oder die Top einhundert, dann äh wird man da vielleicht andere Sperrquoten äh feststellen, beziehungsweise ein im Südsudan gesperrtes Video, das sich an Südsudanesen richtet, kann ja niemals in irgendeiner Topliste landen.
Gesperrt ist. Also das ist eine das ist eine äh dessen Fakt, den man hier im,
mit berücksichtigen muss
Wenn man aber einfach mal davon ausgeht, dass dass diese top tausend Videos dann eben äh diejenigen sind, die in der westlichen äh Welt Menschen interessieren und das dann mal eben ins Verhältnis zu UK und äh USA setzt, dann ähm.
Sieht man da, dass dass diese, dass dieses Speerausmaß besonders groß ist. Was ich aber betonen möchte, ist, dass also die GEMA mit dieser Zahl dreiundfünfzig Prozent möglicherweise rechte Probleme durchaus ähm auch den,
Das äh Versagen, dass Übertreiben äh oder das Fehlverhalten auf Seiten von YouTube anprangern kann.
Na ja, also auf jeden Fall äh es bleibt,
unterhaltsam im Bereich GEMA und YouTube und ist auch noch komplett offen, finde ich, wie das jetzt ausgeht. Äh die Zustellung der Klage, die sie ja jetzt äh eingereicht haben
etwas dauern, wenn ich's richtig äh gelesen habe, äh geht man jetzt von einigen Wochen Zustellungszeit aus, bis das eben diesen Rechtsprozess äh wirklich da durchge,
macht halt, weil es natürlich auch was anderes ist, eine deutsche Firma zu verklagen oder eine kalifornische, also im Prinzip müssen sie ihre Klare jetzt eigentlich komplett neu äh schreiben und neu formulieren und neu recherchieren
weil wenn sie es wirklich ernsthaft davon ausgegangen sind, dass sie jetzt hier auf Basis deutschen Gesetzes vorgehen können, ja?
Dann muss die Rechtsabteilung sich nochmal äh ein paar bisschen externe Expertise dazu holen. Ja ähm.
Abschließend, wir möchten nochmal sagen, dass sie dieses,
Diese Visualisierung, ich finde das wie wie jedes Einzelprojekt von Open Data City bin ich wieder äh sehr begeistert, auch von der von der optischen,
Ausarbeitung, aber auch hier, was Open Data City macht, ist eben vernünftige,
differenzierte Statistiken und Visualisierungen bieten und die muss man dann,
eben auch, die kann man nicht undifferenziert betrachten. Da kommt nicht eine Zahl bei raus, sondern muss man eben die äh Zahlen auch durchaus mal ins Verhältnis setzen. Insgesamt denke ich ein sehr,
Äh wieder mal ein Coup von den Jungs, äh der eine einfach eine
einfach mal wieder zeigt, was ja, was so was man mit so etwas machen kann, ne? Was wie viel Beitrag man leistet zu einer Debatte, dadurch, dass man einfach mal sagt, hier, Zack, Erhebung, Faktenbums, ja, ich bin ja sowieso für ähm,
Evidenzbasierte äh Politik äh Wissenschaft und so weiter und ähm das finde ich hier auch mal äh,
eine evidenzbasierte Einschätzung des Problemes mal vorzunehmen.
So, weiter geht's. Netzneutralität.
Wir kommen jetzt in den in den Teil der Kurzmeldungen, glaube ich. In in Slowenien gibt's jetzt auch ein Netzneutralitätsgesetz. Ja, das ist schön, das ist der zweite äh EU-Staat, der das hat.
Erste Woche lang. Richtig? Holland. Holland.
Der erste war Holland. Ähm wir hatten das, glaube ich, etwas ausführlicher auch behandelt ähm in unserer.
Oh nein, ich hasse es, wenn mir sowas passiert. Jetzt habe ich in diesem Wordpress-Fenster ein Fenster würfelt. Okay, äh ähm nach nach das kennst du das? Ist ganz schlimm. Du du bist quasi in dem Artikelentwurf und klickst versehentlich einen Link,
dann ist in dem Wordpress Editer Fenster auf einmal die Seite drin. Ja, guck mal hier, jetzt ist äh der Artikel ist jetzt hier in dem.
Was das jetzt fürs Urheberrecht bedeutet, wenn ich da jetzt auf.
Ja, das ist äh.
Ja, so ungefähr ist das hier, ne? Wir können nicht genug kriegen vom Internet.
Ähm okay, Slowenien ähm wurde schon im Dezember äh angenommen,
Ähm ein Anfang Januar oder Ende, Ende Dezember offiziell im Amtsblatt veröffentlicht. Und die haben jetzt ähm.
Sogar ernst gemacht und sie haben es sogar richtig ernst gemacht und gesagt,
vor allem Artikel zweihundertdrei Absatz fünf, untersagt es Providern unterschiedliche Preismodelle auf Basis der Internetdienste zu erheben.
Das ist einfach mal konkret, ja? Das ist einfach mal konkret. Sagen, zack, bumm,
keine Preismodelle auf auf dessen Basis. Fertig. Ende. So. Thema erledigt. Ist jede Diskussion über Netzwerk oder,
jeder Vorstoß über einen Verstoß gegen Netzneutralität ist damit beerdigt. So, wenn er sagt, wir haben unterschiedliche Preismodelle. Das heißt, so etwas wie der Spotify, äh T-Mobile, Spotify Orange Steel.
Einfach nicht möglich.
In Slowenien so nicht stattfinden.
Mhm. Das finden wir gut.
Ähm noch auf der Liste der Länder mit Netzneutralitätsgesetzgebung steht ja Chile. Wir hatten schon mal festgestellt, dass wir keine Ahnung haben, wie's in Chile dazu kam
finden wir aber gut. Und ich lese Belgien äh möchte auch langsam einen haben. Ich freue mich jedes Mal, wenn äh so etwas äh passiert.
Ähm denn wir es besteht ja noch Hoffnung, dass sich in Deutschland oder auf der EU-Ebene äh was riecht. Im Moment ist das nicht der Fall, obwohl wir ja Studien haben, die belegen, dass andauernd die Netzwerk,
verletzt wird, obwohl der Markt äh hier ja zur Regelung angehalten ist.
Genau, was auch passiert. Es besteht noch Hoffnung.
Hoffnung steht zuletzt.
So und dann noch eine kurze, ganz, ganz kurze Meldung. Wir haben ja äh die Kirsten Fiedler von Edri äh schon zu,
Gast gehabt und ähm eine nicht, nichts, nicht überraschende,
neue Meldung ist, dass jetzt der Ministerrat versucht, diese Datenschutzverordnung zu schwächen. Äh Kirsten hatte das ja bereits äh ausführlicher auch geschildert, was es da gibt, ist ein ähm schönes,
Infoheft,
Verein digitale Gesellschaft, an dem ich überhaupt nicht mitgewirkt habe und was mich von dem ich kaum mitbekommen habe, dass es entstanden ist. Das aber sehr gut aussieht,
und ähm nochmal dann einen sehr schönen Überblick gibt und ähm.
Ich schlage vor, dass äh den Link zu klicken und sich das anzuschauen und runterzuladen,
sehen nämlich gut aus. Es ist gelungene Infobroschüre, ähm wo nochmal Themen, die Themen nochmal genau drin aufgeklärt sind, auch Begriffe geklärt werden. Das ist äh richtig gute Arbeit, die ich ähm über die ich mich freue.
Also hier in zehn äh Punkte PDF zum Runterladen und natürlich hier äh verlinkt und äh Original verkorkt von Logbuch Netzpolitik.
So sieht's aus.
So
Wir sind am Ende der Sendung angelangt.
Gut, das ist ja auch mal was.
Gibt's noch irgendwas? Willst du noch irgendwas erzählen? Wie wie äh wie äh lange sind wir hier?
Wie lange wir schon senden, wir sind noch unter einer Stunde. Das würde ich auch vorschlagen, dass wir dabei bleiben. Und.
Trotz.
Verweisen damit äh in die äh,
Die Zukunft, die wahrscheinlich sich schon für uns in der nächsten Woche äh wieder abspielen wird. Wir haben auch so ein paar Sachen in der Hinterhand, über die wir noch nicht sprechen wollen, aber wir,
bedeuten das einfach mal an.
Wir deuten an, dass wir was haben, worüber wir noch nicht sprechen.
Genau, solche Füchse,
und äh ja, da sprechen wir dann später drüber.
Ähm sprechen wir später über so eine kleine Andeutung machen. Es hat was mit äh mit äh Podcast zu tun.
Wirklich.
Ja, ja, ja, ja, ja. Achso und dann muss man, glaube ich, noch erwähnen, äh,
oder hat uns den Effekt verpasst.
Dafür werden wir ihnen jetzt kollektiv mit Watteborsch hinschmeißen.
Tschau, tschau.